We cannot be distracted by Donald Trump's
antics from the real crises and real responsibilities
and duties that we have.
The virus, police killings, protests devolving
into chaos and violence.
Removing Trump must be done.
But Trump is very aggressively trying to distract
us.
I already told you some of the ways earlier.
And the latest is Trump tweeting that he will
be designating and TFA as a terrorist organization.
Donald Trump, of course, announcing this on
Twitter, saying, quote, The United States
of America will be designated designating
and TFA as a terrorist organization.
There's a few different things to talk about
here.
And TFA is a militant left wing movement that
stands for and Thai fascism and TFA.
OK, that's where the name comes from.
And TFA is not centrally organized.
It's a sort of umbrella designation.
And TFA, I see, is more of a strategy than
a group of people per say.
And sometimes they do violent things that
I vehemently oppose.
I have been endlessly critical of many of
the tactics employed by individuals organizing
under the umbrella of Antifa.
It appears, though, that what Donald Trump
is trying to do here is not actually constitutional
in designating them a terrorist organization.
The United States State Department has a list
of terrorist organizations.
They are foreign and TFA is not foreign and
TFA is a domestic group.
Even more importantly, if Donald Trump were
to designate and TFA as a terrorist organization,
they would lose some First Amendment protections
which apply only to foreign terrorist organizations.
So understand that this is part of the framing
by Trump and William Barr that the recent
protests and unrest are merely left wing anarchists
looking to do violence and so chaos.
Now, to be clear, there is no shortage of
anarchists all over the political spectrum
doing protesting, many with ulterior motives.
But there is also plenty of right wing Astroturf.
There is police escalation by way of haphazard
pepper spraying, shooting at media, et cetera.
And this entire story of this is not genuine
anger and frustration with policing in America
or whatever else.
These are provocateurs coming in from outside
that is being used to single handedly devalued
the complaints and concerns that the protesters
have.
And we can't fall for that.
But this claim from Donald Trump that he will
be designating Antifa as a terrorist organization,
it's a political statement.
It is not a law enforcement statement.
It's really important to understand that.
And it doesn't appear to be a legal statement
either.
Trump really cannot designate a domestic group,
a terrorist organization.
It would deny them their First Amendment rights.
It would also deny them due process.
And it is likely unconstitutional.
And it's not something Trump is going to be
able to do.
He may not even really try because understand
the State Department's list of foreign terrorist
organizations.
You just can't put Antifa on that list.
But he said it on Twitter.
And that's the whole point.
That's the big picture here.
This is another attempt to distract.
We must keep our eyes on the ball.
Trump has failed on Corona virus.
More than one hundred and five thousand have
died, 50 or 60 percent of those those deaths.
Those deaths could have been prevented by
a two week earlier, a request from Trump for
a 50 state stay at home order and actual testing
capacity.
On that note, I don't want to get you to something
boring, but understand Trump's tweeting about
designating and Tifa a terrorist organization.
We still, after four months, aren't testing
five hundred thousand people a day in the
United States.
We still, after four months, aren't at the
absolute minimum testing.
We need to really look at reopening the country.
We have national unrest with protests, violence,
looting, destruction of property, arson.
Trump's tweeting about an TIFA and that the
White House will release vicious dogs.
To go after protesters if they get past the
fence.
Oh, and by the way, the wall isn't being built.
Trump didn't repeal and replace Obamacare
with something better like he said he would.
His trade war with China has failed.
Twenty five percent of the workforce is out
of jobs in the last 10 weeks.
So, of course, Donald Trump is time trying
to take credit for Space X and make this about
an TIFA and otherwise pretend that he's doing
a great job.
It is an abject failure that we have not seen
in the United States for a long time.
I mean, you have you have to look at Bush's
failure on 9/11 when he said, let's go into
Iraq, even though they didn't they didn't
have anything to do with the 9/11 attacks.
And this is all meant to distract.
It actually is starting to feel like it may
not work.
If you look at polling, cautious optimism
that what Trump is doing to distract isn't
working.
Assume nothing.
Every one of us has to vote in November.